love and marriage that's the secret to
happiness according to the property
brothers drew and Jonathan are opening
up to People magazine about the new
additions to their close-knit family
girlfriends Jacinta Kuznetsov and Linda
Pham
Jonathan admits his long-term
relationship is the most humbling
unexpected fantastic place to be in my
life I've never been happier
while newly-engaged drew adds I've
always been focused on work so to have
this beautiful woman in my life and
knowing we're going to get married it's
amazing
the brothers who developed a secret
language as children still live together
part time in Las Vegas in what they call
the family compound it was so strange
being exciting and wonderful growing up
in our household because like our
friends would all come over and they
would sit stunned and silent because my
parents are goofballs that's where we
get it from as the family focused pair
approach 40 they're thinking about
becoming goofball parents themselves
drew says I'm definitely looking forward
to having kids Linda and I have talked
about it and we've considered adopting I
think we could have our work cut out for
us despite the huge success of property
brothers their spin-off shows and books
the twins are still Vancouver country
boys at heart we've got a ranch
we really have the same friends we
really have the same routines and
not a lot of that exchange I mean
granted Jonathan has a huge head but
it's not ego suggests he physically says
like I can't wear hats very large it's
actually my shame I have a large